the escalating trade battle between the
US and China is rocking investors around
the world market futures predict a
rebound on Wall Street today after the
worst day of the year for stocks major
indices lost around 3 percent or more
yesterday the Treasury Department is now
labeling China a currency manipulator
this means the u.s. is officially
accusing Beijing of devaluing its money
to gain an unfair competitive advantage
in international trade CBS News business
analyst Joe Schlesinger shows what this
worsening dispute means for your money
good morning Jill good morning so what
is the fallout of this escalating trade
war for the economy well forgetting
about the markets for a second we know
that the overall US economy was already
slowing down manufacturing activity at a
3 year low just yesterday we got some
information out of the service sector
it's starting to feel the pinch as well
you add this on top of it and now we
have to say what are the Trump tariffs
targeting they are targeting consumer
goods that we use every day we're
looking at an alarming drop in exports
right yeah I presented yes so we have
the imports are down of course but also
exports so that hurts manufacturing but
if you look at this next round of
tariffs that was announced last week to
go into effect on September 1st laptops
cell phones no toys clothing all these
things could rise in price because those
tariffs might get passed along to
consumers right now consumers are doing
really pretty well if these prices start
to inch up will they spend as freely the
big concern among economists is that
they don't and that would slow down
growth even more in the second half of
this year the idea of China being a
currency manipulator for people that
don't understand exactly what that means
what is that they're bad in a worse
symbolic more than anything else yeah
there used to be a way that you can go
to the IMF and do something about this
but this is a largely symbolic label it
is important to note that we haven't
labeled China a currency manipulator
since the 90s so 25 years since that it
just brings the trade conflict to
another more serious level and when you
look at sort of the escalating tensions
with us in China
can you just take us back to how we got
here
well you know if you go back we had it
we had tariffs on 250 billion dollars
worth of goods that came into China
there's a 25% tariff there now China
been retaliated they put tariffs on US
goods into China now we have this new
round that could be coming out September
1st the 300 billion dollars of goods
that are not currently under a tariff
would be tariffs by 10% China then comes
out and says hey we don't have that many
more goods to actually put tariffs on to
come in from the US we are going to
weaken our currency why they want to
make Chinese products more affordable in
the global economy u.s. says that's
unfair a lot of people I talked to think
that these new tariffs are going to 25%
in a hurry we are looking at a lot of
pressure on US consumers that that
happens y'all any sign an end to this
trade war nothing on tap
alright Jill Schlesinger thank you very
much